exposition exposition conjointe de
peinture au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux sylvie demers
expose ses monochromes jaunes et rouges
aux côtés de neuville un dialogue
pictural à découvrir jusqu'au 27 octobre
sylvie vient de viroflay et expose
jusqu'au 27 octobre au conservatoire des
arts de montigny je présente des oeuvres
qui ont comme thématique
l'élément marin c'est à dire en fait le
champ contre la roche et nous aussi on
regarde et que dans le mouvement on y
voit effectivement un mouvement d'eau et
aux mouvements des plumes
on n'est plus dans l'abstraction dans
l'autre pièce je raconte plus
d'histoires
donc ce sont des oeuvres qui sont un peu
plus anciennes qui sont travailler de
façon plus architecture et je suis plus
à la recherche d'émotions
donc je raconte plus ma vie à travers
c'est ce que je propose de regard et moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est non parce que j
ai raconté mais ce que le seul qui passe
va pouvoir y trouver en écho à ce qu'il
est l'oeuvre d'art comme miroir du
spectateur une pensée que sylvie partage
avec un ami de longue date neuville pour
la première fois les deux artistes
exposent ensemble
neuville présente ses créations
originales des peintures sur planches de
bois ça c'était un désir qui m'est venue
au vu de
deux planches dans mon atelier de
bricolage entre guillemets au début
c'était des bouts de des chutes de bois
qui traînait mais maintenant je
je martyrise un peu le bois avant de le
travailler
hu a carrément un coup de à coups de
marteau ou je casse il faut qu'il faut
qu'une cassure une brisure rabot scie
circulaire tous les moyens sont bons
pour provoquer un accident sur le
matériau de base
place ensuite à la peinture et à l'ajout
de matières différentes résine polyester
ardoise ouvert
les peintures poser de neuville et les
toiles accrochées de sylvie communique
échanges coloré dialogue thématique des
fils invisibles se sont tissés entre
leurs oeuvres
cet aspect de planches il ya toujours la
planche qui appareille un peu de couleur
fait référence aussi au bois qu'on peut
trouver en bord de mer bien que ça soit
pas l'histoire de ces bois à lui mois-là
j'évoque l'élément marin est lui quelque
part il ya le
le bois qui peut venir d'un navire
fantôme qui a laissé ses couleurs sur la
plage l'exposition de sylvie de mai et
neuville est à découvrir au
conservatoire des arts de montigny
jusqu'au samedi 27 octobre nous allons
nous arrêter à présent sur le travail de
charlotte lelong bonsoir vous est ce
l'une des sept artistes en résidence à
saint quentin en yvelines actuellement
autour du dessin contemporain dans tous
ses états différentes esthétiques et
techniques à découvrir et première étape
de cette résidence c'est l'exposition
intersection c'est jusqu'au 25 novembre
à la commanderie des templiers à
elancourt on va en voir rapidement
quelques images mais avant de parler
précisément de vos travaux de vos
oeuvres qui sont présentées c'est un
travail avec d'autres artistes sept
artistes sont en résidence
l'idée c'était de faire des oeuvres là
on voit le tout l'exposition qui est
présenté à la vie dieu de faire des
offres qui se répondent les unes les
autres vous avez chaque travail et
chaque artiste de votre côté on a
travaillé chaque artiste de notre côté
en fait puisque au niveau du temps on
n'avait pas forcément non plus la
possibilité de faire un travail commun
est une thématique commune
mais après effectivement on a établi un
choix selon les oeuvres pour que toutes
les amendes soient se répondre une
cohérence pour le parfois des visiteurs
c'est plutôt au niveau de la
scénographie en fait que ça s'est fait
ensuite est pas en amont saisir
l'instant décisif exploration des
espaces quotidien lorsque ces deux des
thèmes des artistes qui ont été choisis
votre thème c'est recherché pour révéler
lettres et l'écho de l'enfant chez
l'adulte
dites nous en plus alors c'est une
partie de mon travail mais en gros c'est
plutôt révélé la fragilité humaine celle
où le salaire tout ce qu'on essaie caché
dissimulé
ça va à peu près d'élections sans moi il
me ressemble à l'autre c'est assez large
mais on va dire qu'ensuite l'enfance est
une thématique qui qui découle de sa et
qui fait partie en fête du travail de la
fragilité humaine au sens large dans la
mesure où pour moi l'enfant est moins
soumillon des apparences et du coup est
plus à même de se montrer autant
extérieurement qu'intérieurement cache
pas il dissimule pas voilà pourquoi en
tous cas c'est autant à la fragilité
parce que je pars du principe qu'on est
fatalement fragile fragile pas dans le
sens faible au contraire mais qu'à
l'heure actuelle dans notre société on
n'a pas le droit de le montrer quelque
part on n'a pas le choix il faut avec le
plus fort le plus beau le plus riche le
plus fin va là alors s'arrêtait beaucoup
d'importance aux détails ça c'est vous
qui le dites quand on vit un petit peu
là l alimentation du travail que vous
faites les gestes qui se traduit ce
qu'il ya derrière l'apparence voilà
c'est comme ça que vous travaillez c'est
par le corps ce que le corps souvent
m'ont trahi que du coup j'exprime cette
sorte de fragilité ou ce malaise celle
ce mal est ce tiraillement qu'on a moins
quelques-unes des oeuvres justement vous
avez réalisé qu'ils sont extraites de
votre site sur lequel on peut retrouver
une grande partie de votre travail vous
pouvez nous commenter quelques jeunes
d'être des oeuvres qui sont présentées
alors en fait tout ça ça ce sont des
portraits dont il ya 18 par très
différents
sûr qu'ils se nomment enfance 2 est donc
là ça va être un travail plutôt de
mémoire et sur l'enfance donc cette
enfance qu ont finalement qu on oublie
qu'on en oublie souvent qu'on a été
enfant donc on la met de côté et puis
finalement elle ressurgit quoi qu'il
arrive par moments donc voilà ça c'est
un travail en noir et blanc qui découle
d'un premier travail ou ses des
portraits à l'aquarelle
que dire de plus c'est techniquement
justement vous parlez de qualité qui
vont travailler comment parce que ses
crayons feutres et crayons feu big
aquarelles beaucoup aussi et encre
aquarellés et transfère au
trichloréthylène nous classer un peu
plus technique
c'est en quoi alors le transfert en fait
par exemple donc les oeuvres qui sont en
noir et blanc les portraits qu'on voit
la commanderie sa part d'aquarelles donc
de la série enfin cendre que je
photocopies en fait on est obligé de
passer par la photocopie parce que celle
ancre le pigment de la photocopieuse qui
va pouvoir se transférer grâce à un
produit donc trichloréthylène avant mais
qui n'existent plus donc enfin il ya du
substitut donc j'utilise de l'acétone
donc c'est pas tout ça n'est pas très
violent fin voilà la tendance
exactement
donc il faut mettre un masque plutôt
être en extérieur et donc une fois qu'on
a là photocopier on a notre feuille
vierge la photocopier avec le dessin ici
qu'on appose sur le papier et ensuite au
chiffon passe de l'acétone et en fait ça
arrête donc ça reproduit l'image en
effet miroir et ça donne cet aspect
diluer un peu fantomatique et
corresponde mieux justement votre
thématique voilà la fragilise en fait le
trait et ça le rend fou et donc voilà ça
accentue en fait mes propos donc c'est
une technique que j'utilise beaucoup de
personnes ne se fait pas je vais donner
votre date de naissance 1985 et
m'excuser ça ne se fait pas mais c'est
lié à ma question est est ce le fait
d'être né justement dans les années 80
et d'être encore jeune ce qui me
concerne aussi c'est une problématique
cette fragilité des trentenaires de
l'enfant qu'on essaye de garder en soin
de dissimuler mais qu'on conserve quand
même parce que c'est très dans l'air du
temps aussi
alors peut-être c'est vrai que moi je
non je sais que c'est lié à la joue pas
ou pas par exemple en disant est ce que
vous aurez le même genre de ça je ne
sais rien je peux pas vous répondre à
l'heure actuelle mais je pense qu'en
général un artiste a toujours la même
problématique finalement après voilà les
questionnements sont différents en
fonction du contexte et de l'âge
peut-être de l'artiste mais je pense que
c'est une passe que vous vous adressez
avec quel public à travers ses heures
est-ce que vous ciblez votre public ou
non
non pour moi c est là tout public qu'ils
soient âgés jeunes de sexe féminin ou
masculin
en revanche je pense que c'est un
travail très subjectif et
qu'effectivement beaucoup de personnes
peuvent ne pas être touché ou non pas
envie d'être touché par ça parce que
c'est quelles que soient leurs
fragilités refouler leurs enfants ces
refoulés aussi et que voilà ils vont
passer devant aucun intérêt ou sujet
trop personnelle à l'artiste en fait
cette réflexion qu'on vous a déjà fait
non mais enfin si moi j'ai fait les
beaux-arts de rennes et c'est vrai que
oui lors de mon diplôme sa fin on peut
me dire c'est un sujet peut-être très
personnelle parce qu'au final on se rend
compte que c'est assez haute sans fin
avec du recul je me rends compte que
c'est très autobiographique aussi donc
voilà il ya certaines personnes qui
peuvent se dire finalement c'est sa vie
en cela elle nous touche pas ou admet
enfin ça ne nous regarde pas via cette
exposition dont qui est proposé
actuellement la commanderie de
lavilledieu y en aura une autre
également dans le cadre de cette
résidence ce sera à magny les hameaux
fin novembre également à guyancourt en
juin 2013 ce sont des travaux différents
qui vont être présentés à chaque fois
alors à magny les hameaux je suis tout
seul donc ça va être essentiellement des
portraits à l'aquarelle
seul manquait donc ça a été choisi avec
avec la ville de magny les hameaux
en revanche en juin ça sera une
exposition collective donc à 2 est donc
là je pense qu'on va faire un
on va produire des oeuvres ont semblé
essayer de travailler autour d'une
thématique donc pour l'instant c'est
voilà c'est en cours donc ouvert et
singer est justement ça va changer votre
façon de travailler le fait de la faire
une résidence avec cet artiste six
autres artistes 7,7 en tout ça change
notre façon de travailler vous
nourrissez autistes que font les autres
ya des échanges entre tous ces artistes
alors oui évidemment après c'est vrai
que là dans le cadre de cette résidence
on n'est pas on est chacun il ya sept
partenaires donc sur saint quentin en
yvelines et chacun a ses propres
enfin je veux dire chaque chaque
partenaire a choisi tel ou tel artiste
donc après on peut être amené à
travailler à deux ou à trois ou à quatre
comme l'a par exemple vous avez
travaillé à 2 voilà là on va travailler
donc effectivement c'est la tâche que
vous êtes vous allé imposer votre façon
hors honoraires de l'autre comment on
travaille quand on est artiste meiser
oui après après ça dépend effectivement
maria il ya tout type de travail et il y
en a des collectifs - c'est vrai que je
suis plutôt solide elle j'aime
travailler chez moi même aux beaux-arts
je travaillais chez moi et non pas aux
beaux-arts puisque voilà après l'idée
travail à deux je pense qu'au contraire
en plus on a des thématiques qui se
rejoignent ces deux voilà c'est de se
nourrir l'une de l'autre donc on est de
deux filles et de voir ce qu'on peut
développer ensemble pas d'imposer une
toute dernière question il ya aussi des
ateliers 29 au 31 octobre à
magny-les-hameaux justement comment ça
va se passer ça s'adresse aux enfants
déjà et c'est sur la thématique
justement des comment on se voit comment
les autres nous voient et chacun des
enfants va devoir créer des silhouettes
oui dessinée l'autre en créant des six
mètres puisque l'idée c'est que ce soit
ludique donc le matin c'est dès 4 ans et
l'après midi les ateliers seront dès 8
ans
voilà donc l'idée c'est qu'ils
commencent à observer l'autre et qui par
des on parlait de détails tout à
l'heure alors qu'elles détaillent fonds
que cette personne est cette personne là
et non pas une autre c'est facile ça
pour les enfants je ne sais pas l as
roma première fois je pense pas mais
l'idée c'est dévoile à développer leur
regard et on va voir ce que ça donne
merci charles auteur ou artiste son
corps en résidence sur saint quentin en
yvelines exposition actuellement la
commanderie des templiers à vis du à
elancourt et puis ces trois jours
d'ateliers les dates qui se sont
affichées du côté de magny les hameaux
merci à vous côté actualité aujourd'hui
on en parlait en début d'émission pad
abattoir mobile dans les yvelines il ya
un peu moins d'une heure vous avez
entendu le porte parole des musulmans de
saint cyr l'école qui nous donnait son
point de vue une interview que vous
pouvez retrouvez également sur notre
site internet mais pour mieux comprendre
ce dossier nous faisons un point complet
avec toutes les réactions des
responsables politiques du département
avec ce reportage de signer à l'izk à
steel pan vendredi 26 octobre la fête de
l'aïd pour les musulmans de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'annonce un
peu particulière en effet l'abattoir
mobile qui permettait aux familles de
procédé au rituel du sacrifice d'un
mouton ne fonctionnera pas le dispositif
était installé sur un terrain
d'elancourt le matériel appartient à la
ville mais cette année son maire et
ancien parlementaire jean-michel
fourgous ne veut plus assumer les coûts
de son exploitation
il renvoie la question au nouveau député
socialiste et c'est le député qui
coordonne plusieurs communes qui donne
l'impulsion qui trouve les moyens
financiers et qui se coordonnent avec
l'état bien sûr pour réussir une telle
opération
c'est une très grosse opération le
député n'a pas de compétences juridiques
et techniques pour pour pour intervenir
une fois de plus je trouve vraiment
irresponsable de la part
du maire de du maire d'elancourt qui a
été battue nayyar aux législatives
d'entretenir à dessein cette confusion
c'est vraiment le maire d'elancourt la
ville elancourt qui propriétaire de
l'abattoir
c'est elle qui a maîtrise le foncier
ainsi que les procédures qui jusqu'à
présent ont été mises en place pour
l'organisation cette fête religieuse
après cet abattoir n'a de réalité les
deux sens juridique que par la
délégation des règles d'hygiène que
l'état donne ou mer et ça concerne les
mères et les collectivités locales
j'ai été député pendant excusez moi de
dire ça j'ai été député pendant 14 ans
ma mission de député la mission des
députés je la connais un peu un voile a
cessé de faire les lois et de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
fin juillet la communauté
d'agglomération avait proposé comme
alternative aux musulmans un marché au
vif proposition rejetée par le collectif
de saint quentin
car jugées non conformes aux rituels le
maire de la verrière encourage lui les
musulmans à s'organiser eux-mêmes que je
défends et je compte bien défendre la
position d'avoir une solution pérenne
qui permettent
la prise en charge par les associations
musulmans de cette pratique est donc on
aide à trouver une solution durable
quand le plus vite possible dès l'année
prochaine ça c'est vraiment tout le
monde se met au travail ou honnêtement
il ya suffisamment de terrain il suffit
de se poser un tout petit peu je suis
sûr quand on mord à vis de la bonne
volonté
jointe par téléphone l'association des
musulmans de trappes dit craindre une
pagaille la plus totale et parle même
d'un retour de dix ans en arrière
les abattoirs les plus proches à savoir
dreux et creil leur ont proposé une
centaine de moutons un nombre
insuffisant sachant que l'an dernier
mille trois cents bêtes avaient été
sacrifiés à elancourt en l'absence
d'abattoir temporaire sur le département
la direction départementale de la
protection des personnes redoutent que
les familles musulmanes et massivement
recours à l'abattage clandestin interdit
pour des raisons de sécurité sanitaire